citizens of the reject Nation how are you you
lovelies it is time for another installment of we
didn't have a childhood full of DC animated films
who are making up for it now and people think
in the comments that we have already seen them
and we're like no we haven't did these comments
make no sense why are we reacting to something
surprising guessing things wrong if we've already
seen them the series and we hope you're enjoying
it please do like subscribe hit that notification
Bell let us know which one of these you want to
watch next because you may have noticed last week
last episode last time we concluded the dcam you
hey how you feeling about today's I am excited
to go into areas Uncharted koi we're going back
in time back into the past so to well-charted
territory for others Uncharted for me that's how
2010 feels 2023 old very long ago also speaking
of old the opposite of that new shirts we got a
bad first shirt it's got three Batman some might
say the best three Batman you can argue in the
comments I think Christian Bale might be on that
shirt next time but batford shirt is available
right now at our shop subzeroedition.com and
this summer coming soon to a Comic Con near you
the real rejects we're gonna be there Saturday the
22nd more details to come but if you're there
on Saturday look for these Rejects and alas
foreign are you a patron are you sexy
have you joined the sexiest Nation the
reject nation of the sexiest caliber
because you should because that's how
you watch this whole thing front to
back begin and with our resting faces
and only the patrons get that experience so get
on over there and join us and without further
Ado this is 2010's Justice League crisis on
how many Earths just the two just the two
I didn't drive back then yet I
know I was gonna say we're not
opening up with a Chase or a you know
any transportation Metropolitan Street
is this the same clown guy from a few movies ago
in the AMU continuity it must be because I don't
think Joker has ever been quite the jester he
is here the quantum trigger now we have a chance
Quantum that's timey why me
I was gonna say we're gonna get that 2010
animation flavor too yeah see how things
have changed [Music] I'm getting named him
I might not have realized that's like Lex
Luthor guessed that first yeah unless
in this universe they're good guys and
the Justice League's bad could be it's time
to get seriously no we can make it together
we can do this that's your shiny bald
head out of here it's hurting my eyes oh
[Music] what can I say
dang just murdered
okay okay I'm down to my last joke anyway I
guess it must be the joke but this one will
kill you [Music] whoa Luthor oh this is so fun
oh it is that they're the bad guys Ultra Man
owl over there Earth two you'll get a pie for
what you've done mate I'm going to
finish the job the jester started
I was right the first time
dude he's got goth eyeliner that means
he's very evil he is dramatic he has
seen some stuff Sinister raised by Mom pocket
somewhere not in Kansas Billy Baldwin in Philly
the darkness of Philadelphia Mark Harmon
multiversal content topical I know right
and Now's the Time while everyone's exhausted
we should watch this while everyone's seen a
lot of it don't worry in every other Universe
we're watching a singular timeline fair fair
I love this this is great scope of it [Music]
yeah the Batman man a good opening titles is
underrated it really is it brings you in hey Josh
Keaton's in this we were just talking about hey
Spider-Man himself Nolan North I love Nolan and I
love this too like giving us the hint of like okay
here's who's who yeah I like that too dang cool
do you think they're going to argue
over which is Earth one all right flash
beginning test run you're absolutely
sure it works pretty sure pretty sure
there's even a one percentage good
enough cool teleporters online [Laughter]
fat carbs no need to make a scene I want
you to contact the Justice League for
me or else I'll destroy the world is
that sufficient uh it's up down here
[Music]
yes oh and they call me the Flash
you're going to find what I have to say
very difficult to believe you're from a
parallel Earth your internal organs are
reversed your heart is on the wrong side
wowie thank you Mark Harmon Superman but our
Luther is still in his cell on Striker's Island
and now that we've clarified the matter of my evil
twin story to tell you pants turns out I was armed
after I call them little Lex oh I'm not just the
leader of my world's Justice League I'm its only
surviving member we were systematically destroyed
by a group of super-powered beings known as the
crime syndicate in the hope of maintaining
some minimal order the authorities simply
pretend they aren't there but increasingly they
refuse to be ignored well yeah you people are my
World's Last Hope we have to discuss this please
wait out here your call is very important to us
it's another thing that is sort of surprisingly
become a favorite beat I love twists on
Lex [Music] and of course willing to help she's
right that's what we do not this time oh but we're
talking about millions of people we can't just
turn our backs we have to go what if you split
up Batman you go build stuff we're gonna go save
the rest of us will take care of this all right
we'll help but we need a plan I have one of course
wait is that what's happening because Batman just
it sort of seems like it I was joking Batman
what are you doing he's gonna have to save
him though once they get trapped he's gonna be
standing here back grumbling I'm gonna bat brood
over this new building Earth City staring
out of the globe any sign of the quantum
trigger if it was here it's not now download
all these records into my personal computer
's place of anything useful then destroy it
God even like the choice in the different
voices is interesting I like the
overhead smash people are moving
orienting but there are no other side effects that
what the hell we're compromised
was this the plan yeah
ow that'll be enough of that oh
it's a level Superman damn [Music]
[Music]
you like a knockoff static shock
it's not going good for him
ice
[Music]
that animation yeah
[Laughter]
this is Marvel
slap in the basement That's What
I Call tuning somebody up that's
awesome can I talk to you for a
minute always don't fall for Flash
I am 10 times the King was that's the crossover
we're waiting for yeah oh no
oh no now we're cocaine bear oh
babe that bear Fame the bear ouch
whoa turn into a rocket beat scissors
well done sir thank you thank you that's how you
know you know your Comics we're in it we were
ready you want to help me I don't want to fight
you I want it hey this is like the Jedi mind trick
that's a Disney property flash yeah
dude I feel like not in a while the
super breath Superwoman's called in
the Cavalry at least three made men almost
as tough as Superwoman made men [Music]
oh crap guys can't fly really you can't like
flap his legs fast enough to tell himself upward
God what a great shot of Superman coming up yeah
it's funny because it's not that old
but it does have a sort of classic
kind of feel to it the weight of them
flying feels different yeah this is
something with like the motion quality
yeah well I think it's more hand-drawn
play [Laughter] nicely done barrels
what was that Black Adam is
that black Adam see a maid man
whoa
it's having a Black Adam vibes laughs
yeah Diana of that too with the claw marks
or I guess are they all like this
Black Adam de facto kryptonians
for this universe oh that's interesting
oh they seem to have lightning abilities
definitely a Black Adam wardrobe yeah for sure
I love that they also look like an
old-timey like villain yeah like
villains but also like magic show act
or something like yeah they have like a
like a vaudevillian yeah that kind
of burlesque show sort of quality
that's it sweet [Music]
I was wondering about that yeah we got
to decide who we're calling up to replace
jarcus Brooklyn Superman over here a
grown mom parking Brooklyn I'm a mad
man begun construction on this the quantum
eigenstate device once completed the QED
will give us life and death power over the
entire planet dangle that knife the device
is Heisenberg uncertainty override allows us to
tap into a limitless pool of destructive energy
we don't have the power to
fight them might doesn't
in the long run it's the other way around we are
always stronger when we're doing the right thing
preach yeah I like that and it's good she's even
got a little slogan yeah the Rhymes I remember
it doesn't make right
Birds of Prey very much
it's not mine it used to belong to a friend oh
R.I.P Jester we hardly knew you not the same
guy but sort of kind of the same guy The Joker the
gesture is never coming back oh Harley's a monkey
each of the family heads have thousands of
criminals working under them they reward
their most trusted lieutenants oh [__] oh
Mr Miracles some sort of and it was a cyborg
it was a Zatanna stand in no more than
seven or eight at a time perhaps fifty
uh we're going to hit multiple targets at
the same time of course we'd be hopelessly
outnumbered when my Justice League fought
them we aren't your Justice League yeah
flashed and boomerang
Matrix cast member and yellow guy hey and
Taxi Driver Lobo from the 80s Lobo Mobo
confidential
[Music] the shipment of torpedo well
this is awkward that was confidential
speedy red and Rosie just red arrow because
he looks adult Speedy I think of his young
Sea Beast
amazing
it's cool that manhunter's actually getting like
a a featured fight here doing stuff and using
his abilities in creative ways yeah right
then Abandoned Ship if you can if you can
sorry Lobo
it's good use of like weight and scale for
that yeah and I love all the power used so far
[Music]
oh clever nicely done and nicely
animated Ultraman I know you can hear me
Jimmy Olsen whoa he ain't here you want an
appointment you can call his secretary clear
our airspace the name is ladies yeah 100 boxes of
Wheaties a day I got the big guy oh yes they got
they dropped the pal I'd rather not have to hurt
you Jimmy of course it's gonna hurt me more than
hurts you oh to call Ultraman get your hands
off my boy you got problems of your own my boy
he Lex yeah especially if you can't kill
like you do have to take him out on your
own I'm here because I'm the baddest of the
bad anybody who ever stood in my way is dead
everybody woof Kryptonite the only thing that
can hurt you damn destroyed the last piece on
Earth true but I've been visiting other Earths
Planet Jersey things are changing when you do
wrong there are more and more of us who aren't
afraid to set it right yeah beautiful oh that
guy the background look at the triumphs yay
we're not dead this is unacceptable Lex what
do you think you're doing oh no that should be
obvious Mr President a Deathstroke yeah I was
gonna say I've already ordered the release
of Ultraman wow I'm sorry Mr President but
we're not about to give up this fight not
when we finally have a chance to win it
poor president Slade Wilson no respect aren't
you supposed to be helping I am helping I'm
improving the Ambiance having to use that that's
a great line somewhere in the Multiverse there
is a world I call Earth Prime the original
and once I destroy it all reality will follow
you got a real death wish man it just
cumulative don't get in my way to the contrary
but but that too I just amen this is not gonna
end well it was nihilists I mean he's gonna
he's gonna shove you off this train at some
point it's coming you get your little girl
under control remember what happened to the first
lady if you come near my daughter I will nuke you
great equalizer huh whoa whoa that was that was
a backhand of Justice yeah seriously I felt that
Luther took the quantum trigger
to a parallel birth would you be
a deer pop over to the universe
next door and pick it up for me
perimeter breach potential Intruder Alert
see he planned to have he knew someone needed to
stay behind so in the lookout [__] was a foot
oh Batman entrance whoa whoa
power loader Batman you're on my
back off before I come over there and hurt
you get away from my property you [__]
and Neo back in oh beautiful also Bruce
Lee a lot of people but NEOS who I love
people back in just saying it's a good backing
your face stay down here I'm
numbered count again [Music]
oh yeah what you guys are
in trouble be up take them
[Music]
you just bring them here from Earth yeah he's just
that was a teleporter he's just popping him in
hot man come on mullet Aquaman I'm here
for it it's good so black and arrow I
think that's an is that static shock
like as an adult who's that guy [Music]
oh not bad
oh yeah nice get him firestorm
is going to be tougher than I thought nah you got
this man even down one floor wanna hear secrets
jeez I was never gonna hear again
Alex expensive stayed behind to fix all
this up I'm just trashing his teleportation
yeah deserve power oh dang static
shocked [Music] that's right
you've got possibilities little man you gotta
type that lip bites the lip bite you're right
she definitely has a type such a great little
flourishes in the animations where else is
yeah I agreed like that stuff you take the
time to do right that's someone drawing oh
we got teleported dang joining me today are
elected officials who aren't afraid to act
together we can win together whoa excuse me
well done arson man answer excuse me Jeremy
John's holding him down how's that working out
for you guys stay away from me maybe two will work
those are some nice boots though cool [Music]
I'll continue to keep close watch on you until the
immediate crisis has passed that'd be just fine
nice moves you remind me
of my boyfriend [Laughter]
look how casual she is about destroying her own
stuff too that's power perhaps a fear an Earth
where Humanity has mutated into hideous creatures
of the night Cronenberg the world you might like
that or it might be fun to keep you as a pet your
call sorry you're not my type dang that's going
to cost you a rib [Music] with a thumb just a
press damn Adam and Eve with a smoke bomb [Music]
at lung capacity it's not smoke
tonight oh no it's anesthetic gas
ah smart man well done what's up
it's two of those I'm on your Earth I
figured out the S stands for Sato masochism
what did you hide on my satellite I
don't know what you're talking about
it's the quantum trigger the Detonator for
a bomb they're building why didn't you just
destroy it it's pure energy it can't be
destroyed also Fair they could use it to
set off an explosion that would wipe out the
entire Earth you think too small yeah I was
gonna say mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling yeah skating cascading cascading
sorry to come in without permission but
Superwoman said to bring this right to you she is
[Music]
our minds are in sync to a degree that
was rare even among my own people I
never imagined I'd meet a human so
complementary to myself I feel it
oh trying to kiss you a way of sharing affection
this is Mars oh my God where are we going
are we getting some Navi hair tendrils what's
happening oh it's like a lovely stare oh [Music]
oh they're like bonding through
memory and like shared happiness
oh maybe not all happens but yeah like the
minds think bonding deeply the good and the bad
[Music]
wow I love that they're actually
spotlighting him in this yeah wow
we know each other huh that's great do you really
think you can beat the crime syndicate if we could
find them I could find out where their base is my
father's known for Years also could we actually
kiss I mean that's that was on my end that
was beautiful kissing is very much more simple
this this makes the physical just you know
boost of superpowers look very fun yeah I
agreed it's like man I would be so handy
this is one of the ones that feels the
most like a movie yeah not like a long episode
or something it feels very cinematic and real
how are we supposed to get
in again multi-frequency
band encryption analyzer replicator
pack some of us don't speak Star Trek
is it just me
no we're fine yeah sure that's never happened
before we've got the bomb everybody does what
we say or else you're bluffing as long as the
bomb's here all you can blow up is your own house
laughs and now the odds are six to three count
again look who I found in the hangar damn it
ah clever
God the sound effects yeah [Music]
not the good pairing nope get out of that bats can
we get everybody with their counterparts please
cool use a mirror like reflection there
it is yes okay the order has been
restored evil Batman versus Batman
excellent on the way just to drive by punch
red and yellow blurs yeah
cool I like the choreography on the fist fights
too yeah and the like the motion and the physics
and stuff like whoa they're actually like
fighting feels like a wrestling match
[Music]
oh fun
no
all right what you got Lex
I always get Batman fighting on a catwalk Bridge
loves them I guess that's where a bat would
hang out and an owl that's where he birthed as
Nemesis is on uh over a vat of acid we found it
is it the real Earth Prime 52 do they all claim
to be Earth Prime he's taking the QED to Earth
Prime if he detonates it he'll destroy all reality
oh man's just taking the bomb to a hiding place
don't try and con me what are you two doing
we're on our Natural Born Killers [__]
and it's does this thing keep in its memory the
last dozen or so but that's more than enough oh
this is a good device I like this device
it's got just enough memory it's practical
locked out unless someone vibrating at the right
speed could piggyback on all man's carrier wave
and open a portal but he'd have to be fast
barreled no you're not you're too slow what
I know your limitations you can't possibly
reach the speed necessary to pull this off
ouch dude ouch he's talking about blowing up
my world too and I'm not letting that happen
it could be dangerous the bloody universe
is at stake of course it's dangerous
fair damn he's really faster than flash flash
ouch you have to hold that speed precisely
oh no treadmill required
come on
oh cool wow nice
hold that speed damn [Music]
enter the speed force go Batman
no hesitation those primes not looking so good
I can't imagine what series of decisions led to
this world hurtling out of its orbit but I know
this the source of the cataclysm was the same as
it always is man huh always you're insane how does
it really matter there are alternate versions
of me that you would find quite Charming yep
oh I gotta say this is a pretty interesting
Wasteland very your attitude your costume
your tactics they all scream of outrage
oh what terrible wrong was done to set
you on this path you forgot Justin what
are you planning to do talk me to death
I thought I'd get you to death hey what
does that say about your attackers damn it
and you could learn a thing or
two from now man cover that mouth
that Manning you must have been a good man once
never good after all I'm only human ouch oh nice
all that math there is a difference between
you and me I'm not wearing hockey pants yes
that is a bar nicely done that cold Planet
I'm guessing because he saved it yeah nice
oh die all alone little man [Music]
it doesn't matter
it was keeping it real to the very
end oh man oh it doesn't matter
beautiful nihilism and yeah like I've
seen so many Wasteland climaxes but
these wastelands were super interesting too
yeah heavy metals sci-fi concept art yeah
oh look at that man Johnny
I'm back stop vibrating oh God
oh wow time dilation he just saved infinite
Earths yeah and what a cool sort of compliment
too it's a Flashpoint in a way did we save
the world then we did and all that rubbish me
being faster than Flash you knew this was
gonna happen always a baby good one mate
oh you can't die you have a crypt to keep I kind
of thought she used to deliver man we need you
that was clever yeah that was good we almost lost
everything that was then now you're a bunch of
wannabe cops trying to take me in I was 40 seconds
ago this is now two things you ain't got the
authority and you ain't nearly Tough Enough The
Authority we are more than Tough Enough brought
the Cavalry I brought the Marines hit the view
the proud the Space Marines yes the space force
hey
Space Marines led by the president himself
that's right man showed up in person it's
that old school American grit you know on
the front lines I've already ordered the
National Guard to support local law enforcement
teams we're rounding up the bad guys everywhere
oh I don't want you to go but I don't belong
here you could I don't belong here excuse me
John but would you stop acting like an idiot this
is what we fight for if you love her stay I mean
we can always come visit you she's already lost
I mean you've already lost your world standards
I've already lost one home I made a promise to
protect my new one oh then this is how we say
goodbye oh that's why they didn't kiss before
we saved it give momona Diana dang beautiful
maybe there's another one like her back on our
Earth with my luck she'll be evil [Applause]
forever I mean that's that's kind
of beautiful but also like damn
that's good to be back home mind your head
oh that's great you can fly you drive a
car what do you do Jeff where you can fly
you drive a car genius explanation
more help around here wouldn't be a
bad idea I'm glad you agree I've been
thinking about a membership Drive ha
KP Justice League hey
that was so good I loved that oh my
goodness that was a delight and like
it literally did everything I wanted that
last Multiverse movie to do really was James
Woods oh yeah no I wasn't kidding Josh
Keaton crushed his Flash all the voices
James Patrick Stewart who's a different guy
different Patrick Stewart yeah oh and Bruce Tim
was Uncle super I love it damn yeah that was so
incredible I loved his multiversal explanation I
loved how cinematic it felt I love that it did the
thing where it made you invested in both sets of
Worlds see this is the thing you do it right right
now is is a time where we're hearing two things
I think a lot which is ah man that Superhero
fatigue and ah man that Multiverse fatigue is
almost I said in the beginning but like the thing
is when you each time you see one that's done well
it doesn't matter right like and and yeah like
watching this at a time where we have like a new
adaptation of Flashpoint we have like a bunch of
other multiversal stories you know dominating the
multiplex probably more to come like this felt
so like I wasn't thinking about any of that I
was just sucked into this and like it was that's
why I like I think Deadpool kills the fox universe
is come like I predicted eight years ago and I
think if they do it right it won't be fatigue
I hope not you know what I mean because like I I
assume it's going to be what we wanted Multiverse
of Madness to be if my assessment of what I think
they should do but I think that we won't be sick
of it like I think if they do it right it's good
like this this was an hour and 16 minutes I know
this was better than any Justice League movie
I've seen in live action and it sweeps you up
in the adventure and in the immediacy and it also
has an interesting take on what its version of the
Multiverse is how it is used and represented and
I mean here this is an example of something where
we don't like hop to a million universes only
two couple other ones others are alluded to but
we're mainly just on these Two Earths even the
credits look at the inverse credit and then the
world spinning in different directions different
like pangeas like it's genius even the credits
are insightful yes like I like this is It's funny
this came out in 2010 because this to me does feel
like a great combo of like it it feels classic
and like to something that would have fallen out
of like the height of the animated DC Series in
the 90s or something like that in terms of like
the craftsmanship and like no shade to the DC
AMU stuff we've been watching in the more modern
stuff but there is something that feels a bit more
tangible in the animation yeah and the nuances of
motion and the little ticks and mannerisms they
give all the characters that are then combined
with the voices and like this was given me like
the best of like what I love and and sort of get
nostalgic for about like you know the animated
shows that I have seen but also things like I
don't know like Parts this had like a watch mini
kind of yeah I mean yeah Alamance certainly like
feeling like a mix of like I mean less night out
and more kind of a doctor Manhattan yeah more
Shack Thing by the end like if you smash those
two together because yeah this whole nihilistic
view on everything and yeah being like the polar
opposite of of Bruce himself and yeah and Ultra
man being such a good antithesis to Superman and
in really different ways yeah didn't feel too
much like uh your traditional like red Sun or
too much like even homelander he felt like his
own different thing that was still the opposite
because of how archetypal these characters are
yeah and like it's funny that they are like a mob
and that they have like you know hey like you know
he's kind of got that you know Brooklyn kind of
accent or whatever which is the anti-kansas sure
and uh family and family yeah and then and
then what's uh I guess the the opposite of
Central City is just Australia yeah there it is
but but that too a dense Metropolis or like the
the Down Under absolutely like like I I love
the tweaks and nuances and the way in which
like yeah you do have a certain amount of
like part versus counterpart but I thought
yeah the way that they drew the characters and
I don't know how faithful this is being to one
particular iteration of this in the comics I
know the name crisis on infinite Earth sure
um but yeah just like the way it realized each of
these different characters it just sort of let you
I think the opening credit scene was really nicely
hewned to you know show you who is who and who
is whose counterparts yeah um but yeah just like
the way they realize those characters and the way
they cast the voices to play off of you know the
voices of the main Justice League we are used to
like this this is just one of those experiences
where like every element felt like it had a lot
of care and you know uh inspiration put on it you
know the production was incredible top to bottom
I mean we talked about the choreography we talked
about the weight in the fights we talked about the
sound design we talked about the score we talked
about the opening credits like when you look at a
movies assemblage it is so many pieces that's why
I personally think seeing movies in theaters is so
important because you need to show your support
for the thousands of people that are involved
because I mean the best boy does more work than
people give credit for there's every element of
these movies in this one we noticed we noticed the
care in the sound design we noticed the care in
how the fights felt like certain Styles we noticed
the care in the characterization so the writing
was top-nosis the directing like this felt like
it had weight like a classic animated movie where
like the hand-drawn frames allow it to feel like
something instead of just like like if you skip
steps you feel it and whether you notice why you
feel it's kind of like The Uncanny Valley like
if you're looking at something that's like that
almost feels human but something's off sometimes
animation does that for me and I I've been very
public about like my disconnect from animation
these movies have really helped me connect to the
animation differently spider-verse is probably the
thing that's helped me most the animation the
first one and the new one but I don't consider
animation um a lesser medium a lot of people
do I think incorrectly I've been to West it
gets sideways that is a thing for kids and and
I don't think that's true and I never have even
when I haven't connected to it but I have started
to connect more with it through things like this
and through movies that have the weight because I
realize that like I was judging my connection on
weak links because of like you know my my seeing
certain things and now that I'm seeing things of
quality it's been really helping my connection
to the entire medium that is animation and this
was one of the better Justice League things I've
seen hard stop yeah right like it was really good
and this had again for for my money money this
had kind of everything you would hope for out
of both a big event you know a big particularly
cataclysmic you know event storyline like this but
also just you know a comic like it has a certain
amount of you know actual implications and debate
and they go see the president and they're you know
they're like great philosophical the implication
of like what is our jurisdiction here like you
know who can we afford to be worried about right
now when we got our own problems die because of
these oppressors yeah and it's like they have
those kinds of things going on but it's not bogged
down and being like a philosophical rumination or
being like way more serious than it needs to it's
got fun but all that stuff's in character and it's
not like too jokey like the the humorous bits feel
uh appropriate to each character and like that
whole thing at the end where it's like oh man he's
like it doesn't matter you know it's so impressive
for the punchline is like the perfect flip side to
the darkness you associate with with nihilism and
like yeah and yeah it has things that feel like
Saturday morning cartoons Justice League but that
also sit right next to stuff that again feels like
you're peering into like a Alan Moore version of
a Justice League story and do the juxtaposition
of every character we've mentioned a couple times
but I love the Batman everything matters ending
with l man's nothing matters yeah and I love that
you know Superwoman kind of juxtaposing Wonder
Woman in a really interesting way because she's
all about conquering whereas Wonder Woman's all
about giving and good like they did such a good
job in dialogue as well as action going like we
know these characters so well yeah and and this is
what I'm talking about with archetypal characters
being uh so multifaceted because we I remember we
watched Injustice and we enjoyed it because we
weren't as connected to the comics I've read the
first two volumes but not the Myriad of volumes
and like I had a good time because it understood
the archetypes of the characters I see this I
think did even better because when I talk about
how good Superman is this shows how bad he can be
without it sacrificing how good he is yeah exactly
and I mean even like it took me a minute to kind
of you know like Mark Harmon Superman man is a bit
more like he's not as warm and custody he's not
warm at all it's interesting I struggled a little
bit in the beginning yeah yeah but I thought at
least his resolve and his like true Comfort yeah
his heart and Compass I thought worked really
nicely and I mean yeah you don't really do
anything with Lowe's you don't really see into his
life but I one thing we've also talked about which
I thought I was like joking about at first but
then they actually dignified with a with Great
Moments was the whole like potential little
romance nugget with uh Jon Jones oh that was a
potential that was acted on that was love no yeah
I was like I bet she she seems kind of into him
and then they actually like mine and they did the
Mind meld and we got a little bit of a deep dive
into his backstory for a minute and most people
have seen of him and and I mean yeah and it is
kind of a fun meme of like Hawkman and Martian
Manhunter like they're always here especially
throughout the DC AMU but like boy did they they
get maybe one line at best and here I was like oh
cool and and I know people complain of like ah you
know he's pretty similar to Superman plus a couple
other little things but I I love the way they used
him here yeah I really enjoyed his character here
and I really like that every small character got
enough a moment that I was invested in them like I
cared about her care about her journey cared about
her dad's cared about all the stuff understood
where everyone was coming from understood like
you know the stakes of the world yeah and I cared
about Batman's goals even though it juxtaposed
the Justice Leagues because where he was coming
from and like our Earth is so good like yeah
dimensions and like how him leaving that there
and like why Lex would leave that there and why
they'd go looking for like every step was genius
yeah and starting out yeah with like Lex and a
de facto Joker jester you know stand-in and this
bond between them like old friend the last two
of the Justice League of Their worlds like such
a beautifully like nice little compelling way to
pull you in and make you go oh maybe the Justice
League is the villains in here like you pointed
out and then and what a great way to tie you to
the New Lex like what a great way to like bring a
naked Lex into this planet and be funny and like
make a good opening it feels so cinematic it feels
like a movie and I love it and I and I have James
gonna watch this one yeah no yes there's no way he
hasn't seen this visit please because yeah I love
the way that they uh you know I get I gather that
this is a frequent thing that happens but twists
on Lex where he like you know ends up working with
the good guys always uh you know I get a big kick
out of that have you heard the latest rumor
about Lex no it's down to two names play them
Jesse Eisenberg and Jonah Hill correct I heard it
here first who's it gonna be who's it potentially
Alexander Skarsgard okay Bill Skarsgard it's
not even kidding it is down to scars guards
just as it was down I mean Liam grams were Liam
Neeson it was Liam Hemsworth or Chris Hemsworth
it is now bill or Alexander skars making
a real weird Thanksgiving James again and
Peter's average is gonna walk into that audition
room and just like break that pool cue in half
and then cast and castellan ah yes I'm absolutely
perfect but I love that a Skarsgard is likely
going to be Lex because I think either would
crush it and they're very different but also
very unnerving yeah yeah no I mean nobody likes
an occult for superman but I did from the jump I
just want Nicole to get like in there the the
Multiverse man it is to to see what all these
choices make a Superman movie I would do with
the Multiverse infinite Earth and and I liked
you know wrapping up I liked the way that they
portrayed and set up their Multiverse what the
reasoning was for how and why it Orcs And That
device that Hopper I think is a really great
it's got slight limitations it feels tangible
in like how it navigates you're like oh yeah
I get how this machine works it's not too mumbo
jumbo yeah 12 or whatever Place yeah members like
it's got the whole lexicon but it only remembers
the history to a certain point you know and it's
like compact like an old phone like a T-Mobile
yes great and uh and and I do love the the with
the Martian Manhunter they left that with like I
believe there's a version of this where he would
stay but he makes the Bolder choice to be like
but no he's committed to his Earth and as much
as this Bond you know would be something worth
staying for I I can't you know it's like I can
see people maybe arguing over a beat like that but
I that just I don't know suggests the kind of well
every decision like I love that simple element
explanation of like there's one where you do
this when we do this and that causes infinite
Ripples and like you could spend a lifetime
looking for the changes or it's kind of like that
explanation was genius yes oh this movie was good
so lovely yeah this is my top third for sure this
one uh this one's up there that had a great time
um we are likely to be ranking the DC AMU
soon but uh when we rank the entire DC uh
animated Pantheon this one's gonna be up there
for sure oh I'm so happy right now it's so good
inspired and joyous and that's what this was
a true joy and uh and yeah like I love I love
all animation but I love especially this stuff
where it's like you can feel the flourishes man
you can feel the art loved it loved it excellent
work I'm gonna pick somebody to give some love
to on this excellent video absolutely let's do a
little patreon of the day shout out let's get it
pandemic Jones my dude you got a good Multiverse
name pandemic I feel like you know pandemic Jones
across many universes could be so many I mean
obviously there's one Universe where you are like
kind of a a corraller a wielder of microbials and
disease right actually but you know I've always
wondered like why isn't there like a pandemic why
isn't there like a virus that you know makes good
things happen that could be one of your worlds or
uh you know in a different world pandemic doesn't
even mean what it means here maybe um it's
just a bunch of actual pans and they're just
everywhere every four lights I don't know what
to do with all this but then you can melt them
down and turn them into something else it's called
being resourceful pandemic you know I would argue
Humanity itself oh is the pandemic of positivity
when wielded correctly sure we replicate rapidly
we are are technically a virus in the way that
we ignore our surroundings and we like we consume
more than we output but when we are a force we
can create so much goodness that it does like
every generation thinks it allows generation
because there's that moment of like we've done
it now but if you look at like what we've we've
been able to accomplish like no other species
has left their planet to our knowledge yet I'm
sure they exist because I don't believe that
there can't be but I do believe that in our our
existence on our Earth we are the only creation
we know that is spread to scale and we invented
language and we invented culture and we invented
these things and that's all as a virus so I would
say the pandemic that you're speaking of that is
that is a good thing is Humanity which pandemic
Jones is part of and his last name being Jones
as I've mentioned another shout out is one of
those names like Smith where it's a common last
name juxtaposing the first name so pandemic Jones
represents Humanity or the spread it of humanity
Spirit of the spread of our of our virtue of
our best virtuous Endeavor yes I think we can
be a good virus this was a peak shout out Cole
you really took it you really took my nonsense
and turned it into something put it together let's
put it together I just wanted to make sure that's
how I feel about that name pandemic Jones is the
spread of virtuous good I mean if that doesn't
inspire you to stay pledged pandemic that's the
tip that's a negative Point all right in every
Universe you were pledged you can't disrupt that
order that's my Superman speech I got nothing else
I can't I can't go higher okay you're good for the
day baby okay good that's it it's not like that
pandemic all the love buddy we'll see you next
time patrons and everybody else much love foreign